In the spring of 2005 during their mating
season, toads in Germany and Denmark began
exploding.
Spewing guts, blood and skin for nearly a
yard in every direction; the disturbing phenomenon
at first baffled concerned scientists, although
they eventually discovered the cause of the
fatal condition.
Observed near two ponds during that spring,
one in the Altona district of Hamburg, Germany,
and the other near Laasby in Jutland, Denmark,
some of the explosions were actually witnessed
by environmental scientists.
First, they began with “several minutes”
of “agonizing and twitching” followed
by the toads blowing up like a balloon, and
then culminating in an explosion.
As the environmental workers noted, after
“the toads burst, the entrails slid out.
But the animals [weren’t] immediately dead
– they keep struggling for several minutes.”
With no explanation at hand, scientists with
Hamburg’s Institute for Hygiene and the
Environment tested the pond’s water quality,
searched for a fungus or virus (the latter
of which was hypothesized to have been transmitted
from horses at a nearby race track), and even
considered the somewhat fantastical notion
that the toads may have been purposely killing
themselves to prevent overpopulation.
(Aside: Ants sometimes do something like this,
for the good of the colony.
Specifically, certain species of ants have
suicide bomber ants.
When these suicide bomber ants encounter enemies,
such as ants from another colony, they will
literally explode, causing a chemical to cover
the enemies around them.
This chemical is extremely sticky and when
it dries will immobilize any enemy ants, eventually
resulting in them dying.
The Forelius pusillus ant also has worker
ants that will sacrifice themselves for the
good of the colony, but this time in a slightly
different manner than the exploding ants.
Every night, the nest of a colony needs sealed
off in such a way that the nest will be undetectable
from the outside, in order to protect it from
predators.
As such, sick ants or ones who are older will
apparently volunteer to perform the task of
staying outside the nest at night.
Once all the rest of the ants are inside,
the sacrificial ants will seal up the entrance
and usually will end up dying from being left
outside.
Even when researchers have collected these
sacrificial ants and taken care of them, they
usually die soon anyways, which is why it
is thought that generally older or sick ants
are chosen for this task.)
In any event, each of these theories on the
exploding frog front were rejected, and authorities
were forced to warn residents away from the
pools until an answer was found.
An eminent amphibian expert from Berlin, Dr.
Frank Mutschmann, carefully examined live
and dead specimens and noticed several interesting
facts:
Each had a small circular incision on its
back
Each was missing its liver
None had any other bite or scratch marks
This last was especially significant, since
it proved that neither rats nor raccoons were
attacking the toads.
Of particular note, however, was the size
of the circular incision, which matched the
size of a bird’s beak.
Knowing how clever crows are, Dr. Mutschmann
theorized the birds were aware that the toad’s
skin was poisonous, but that the nutritious
liver could easily be popped out with little
toxic exposure.
His theory also explained how the toads’
exploding reaction appeared to come well after
they lost their livers.
Since it was mating season, the toads would
have been so distracted by their biological
imperative that they wouldn’t have paid
heed to a few quick pecks:
Only once the liver is gone does the toad
realize it’s been attacked.
It puffs itself up as a natural defence mechanism.
But since it doesn’t have a diaphragm or
ribs, without the liver there is nothing to
hold the rest of its organs in.
The lungs stretch out of all proportion and
rip; the rest of the organs simply expel themselves.
After Dr. Mutschmann’s explanation came
to light, besides being confirmed, it was
soon discovered that exploding toad epidemics
have happened before in Germany and Denmark
as well as in Belgium and the U.S.